in theory
there's no reason why luminar should
exist there's no reason why
i or any member of a team should have
been able to build
what we built you have some of the
largest technology companies
and automotive companies on the planet
that have been trying to solve this
problem for
better part of a decade and beyond but
the fundamental aspect of it
is you have to have that strategic
vision
that level of innovation that blank
slate approach
and just pure drive hours everything
that you need to put into it like no
tomorrow to be able to successfully
deliver and execute
and i think that's that's the reason why
we exist and that's the reason why
some of the greatest technology
companies over generation exist as well
[Music]
founded the company about eight almost
nine years ago with the vision to be
able to build a new type of lidar
sensing system from the ground up
to be able to help enable the autonomous
vehicle industry and
really had to build something entirely
from scratch to meet the very stringent
performance requirements safety
requirements and scalability
requirements that were needed
to be able to see this industry become a
[Music]
reality
you have to build something truly from
the ground up
everything is a challenge you know it's
uh and not not a trivial one
[Music]
you have to be able to ensure that
you're successfully balancing all the
different aspects of the business
beyond the core technology development
and to be able to successfully execute
on that
is something where you're still having
to uh to build the plane as it's taking
off you know and
because you you have to really have that
vision
around where you can be and
of course you know that if you don't get
the technology to work if you can't
solve that
that risk and that problem um then
you're done
it doesn't work but at the end of the
day
it's some motivational driver as well to
make sure that you know you you put in
everything you got into into making sure
that it all happens and
executes successfully
building a hardware product that's
extremely complex
and in the auto industry specifically
those are three
very challenging things that you all
have to combine
and at the time you know i was like you
know 16 17 years old where i say
hey i like imagine this pitch i have
this vision
of creating a new type of laser system
that will allow
cars to be able to drive themselves and
we're going to beat out you know
like the googles of this world and all
the major automakers that they're
you know development efforts they're
going to put into this can you invest a
million dollars and
uh it's um to be totally frank
the overall venture capital community
even even within silicon valley was not
exactly
super receptive to that kind of thing
you know it's easy to invest in
easy to understand software technologies
it's very challenging to really wrap
your head around the implications of
something as complex of this
of course equivalently the rewards are
exponentially greater if you
successfully deliver on it
[Music]
so what you're seeing is basically the
raw 3d
data in the environment that's being
imaged by our lidar sensor so
you can see everything going on here in
real time the different colors represent
different distances
that you can see out in this 120 degree
field of view
from the lidar sensor this is the eyes
of the autonomous car this is how
it can understand what's going on and
navigate
safely through the environment
realistically
manual driving being completely obsolete
that's a 2040 problem what we're solving
for
is being able to allow it to safely
navigate starting on highway scenarios
and then expanding the operating domain
over time
in addition to being able to enable much
safer driving capabilities and
active safety systems on the vehicles
that are here today
the physics behind it how to be able to
make all of this work is really really
hard
and in our case of course you know it
always
checked out always made sense you know
theoretically
and that's where after integrating all
these different things after a year's
worth of work
to be able to have the opportunity to
see it to have it come alive to have it
all work
and now to be powering some of the
futures of the largest companies in the
world in this
transportation industry it is incredibly
inspiring you know to
myself to the team to everyone and
uh what drives us every day
[Music]
the thing that i'm most proud of is is
being able to
show that we've successfully seen this
through that
end to end and showing that
you can have this
almost like david vs goliath scenario in
so many different dimensions
that can all come together and it really
is possible